by now we all know about the attempted
coup in Russia by the Wagner group the
owner of the Wagner private military
contractor Evgeni pregotson escalating
his direct challenge to the Kremlin
today evgeny pregosian the leader of the
Wagner mercenary group says that his
forces have left Ukraine and are headed
into Russia Russian authorities are
telling Wagner Fighters not to follow
their leader evgeny pagosian and also to
take measures to detain him but the
question remains who is this guy behind
the Wagner group that just exposed the
king and Putin's armor for the world to
see who is devgini pregosian well it
turns out the story behind one of the
most dangerous men in Russia is
absolutely insane this guy is an
absolute Maniac born into poverty in
Soviet Russia this guy survived uranium
mines labor camps eventually getting the
green light to stop the Wagner group
from Putin himself becoming a
billionaire in the process this guy has
been doing Putin's bidding in Ukraine
Syria Africa Putin made this guy and now
it looks like he just that puts in the
back or is there more to the story than
meets the eye this is the bloodthirsty
rise of one of the most sanctioned
Russian oligarchs there is yevgeny
pregosian he's completely psychotic I've
watched his videos where he says it and
he's Fearless too he's out on the front
lines for like a year and a half the
guy's a maniac
foreign
guys if you're constantly exposed to
smog and blues like how I was in New
York City recently then you are
definitely shortening your life but
thankfully longevity research has made a
lot of strides lately and researchers
like Dr David Sinclair have been
discovering real ways to mitigate or
even slow down aging altogether and that
is why I take Verso cell being Verso is
a company that translates these
scientific breakthroughs into products
that hold the potential to increase your
longevity and still being does that by
increasing something called NAD Plus in
your body NAD plus is an extremely
important molecule that improves your
metabolism repairs damage DNA and
increases energy production in your
brain immune system and muscles but as
you grow old your nnd levels go down so
you want to supplement the problem is
you can't take NAD plus as a supplement
because it's too big for your cells to
absorb and that is why cell Bean
contains something called nmn
Resveratrol and TMG these three
molecules work together to increase your
NAD levels more than just taking them
individually on their own and that is
why I take the stuff every day I'm super
picky about what I put in my body but
thankfully Verso publishes third-party
testing on their website for every
single batch so you know exactly what
you're getting I can't recommend them
enough and you can get 15 off by going
to ver.so Gig trim with the link below
when you use code jtran so go to ver.so
jtran with code jaketron for 15 off with
the link below thanks to Verso for
sponsoring this video like every other
teenager in the Soviet Union in the 70s
give Guinea pregosian didn't have a lot
going on for him born in 1961 in what is
now St Petersburg Russia his dad died
when he was just nine years old and like
most kids back then he started working
when he was really young but unlike
American Kids his age who were working
like a diner or something to make a
little bit of extra money if Guinea
ended up working in a uranium mine in
Ukraine trying to scrap together enough
money just to survive and as you can
guess working in a Soviet uranium mine
was really tough workers were paid chump
change exposed to Radioactive medals and
they were worked to the Bone for the
glory of the red Empire so when
jonyevguini showed a talent for skiing
and was taken from the Mazda train as a
professional skier he thought that he
had finally caught a break here was his
chance to become something greater but
his luck didn't last just a few years
into his new career you if Guinea was
injured and forced to leave the school
but this time something had changed
unlike the poor starving peasants he
came from yevgeny now tasted opportunity
and he wanted to make something big of
himself but at just 18 years old with no
money he didn't have a lot of options so
he went with the only route that was
available to him crime in 1979 yevgeny
was caught stealing and given a
suspended sentence he was young it was
his first offense so the court thought
that just the possibility of rotting in
a Soviet labor camp would be enough to
scare him straight but they were wrong
evgeny was desperate and that made him
dangerous and just two years later he
was caught again and convicted on
charges of armed robbery and fraud his
punishment 13 years in a hard labor
prison camp for most Russians this would
have been as good as a death sentence
but yet getting was tough and he wasn't
about to let a little hard work and
torture get him down so he started
reading whenever he was thrown into
solitary confinement he would read any
books available to him the prison guard
saw him reading a lot and thought that
it was corrective Behavior or a son that
he had repented for his sins and changed
his ways but that was not
figured that if crime kept putting him
in jail he would have to find a new way
to make money which meant that he would
have to educate himself by 1988 the
Russian Supreme Court was so impressed
by evgeny's change of hearts that they
reduced his sense to 10 years he would
be free by 1990 and even though he had
just spent a decade in one of the
harshest prisons on Earth the fire in
yevgeny had not died he still wanted to
make something great out of himself all
he needed was the right opportunity and
it wasn't long before it came along
foreign
[Music]
Russia being an ex-con had its downsides
no one was looking to hire someone who
had just spent 10 years in jail so
evgeny was forced to settle for a
dead-end job selling hot dogs in an
open-air Market in St Petersburg there
was no way this was ever going to make
him any real money or so he thoughts see
in communism since people can't own
anything and the people are too poor for
luxuries like clothes and cars anyways
the only thing that they can spend money
on is food that's it and in 1990 the
Soviet government forced St Petersburg
residents to start rationing their food
again instead of just being able to buy
what they needed they could only buy
food with coupons that restricted what
and how much food they could buy so when
the ration's food inevitably wasn't
enough the parents would send their kids
out to buy whatever they could from the
streets and that just so happened to be
evgeny's hot dogs soon quote the rubles
were piling up faster than his mother
could count them end quotes and within
just a few years if Guinea expanded his
hot dog Empire to have more than 100
kiosks all over the city earning him his
very first a million dollars now growing
your own hot dog Empire is already
really impressive in itself but what's
extra impressive is that yevgeny did
this in Russia during the 90s which was
an insane time back then as Russia was
transitioning from communism to more of
a free market it was the Wild Wild West
and the only men that got into business
were either gangsters or businessmen
that were tough enough to fight and kill
other gangsters and evgeny was one of
them this guy was as tough as they come
and soon his hot dog Empire was just not
enough with the Soviet Union's collapse
in 1991 Russia had turned into a hotbed
of opportunity people started making
more money and Russians were finally
able to be interested in stuff other
than just work and survival which meant
that anyone opening up a clothing store
a toy shop or selling any sort of new
consumer product was raking in the big
bucks and yevgeny won it in so in 1995
he partnered with the owner of a grocery
store chain to open up a brand new type
of Restaurant in St Petersburg a
restaurant that would bring him into
contact with Russia's Elites including
one man that would change the course of
his life forever
if guinea pig ocean have very big dreams
for his new restaurants as more and more
Russians started making money they began
looking for more places to spend it and
one of the things they wanted that
Russia didn't have was an upscale fine
dining restaurant according to evgeny
his patients want to see something new
in their lives and were tired of just
eating cutlets with vodka young wealthy
Russians wanted to drink party and die
like their European neighbors so evgeny
gave the people exactly what they wanted
he converted an old boat into a floating
restaurant that quickly became Saint
petersburg's most fashionable dining
spot the restaurant became so famous
that eventually even Vladimir Putin
started bringing foreign dignitaries to
eat there Putin loved the restaurant so
much that he even celebrated his
birthday there in 2003 and evgeny
progression was always nearby doing his
best to make a good impression and it
worked according to evgeny Putin liked
his style quote the president saw how I
built my business starting from a kiosk
he saw how I was now above serving a
plate End quotes by the mid-2000s evgeny
opened a catering company focused on
government contracts and thanks to his
connections and popularity he eventually
started supplying food to the Kremlin
earning his nickname Putin's chef and
considering the number of people and
countries that want to poison the
Russian government every chance they got
getting this job was proof of just how
much Putin trusted you have gaining by
the early 2000s you Afghani progression
believed that he had finally made it he
was trusted by Russia's Elite in 2012 he
had received a contract to supply the
Russian military with food for 1.2
billion dollars so somewhere around this
time period pregosian became a
billionaire and life just couldn't get
any better but then Russia invaded
Crimea in 2014 and suddenly a whole new
world of possibilities opened up for
Putin's chef
thank you
Russia's invasion of Crimea was
ridiculously easy within just over a
month Crimea had gone from being part of
Ukraine to being almost completely
controlled by Russia which gave Vladimir
Putin an idea if one part of Ukraine was
so easy to steal why not steal another
and this time his Target was the donbos
region but it wasn't so simple this time
Ukraine's pro-russian government had
just been overthrown which meant Russian
soldiers would have a much harder time
taking land and setting thousands of
Russians home in body bags just wasn't a
good look for his presidency if Putin
really wanted to take Ukraine he would
have to do it under the radar Putin
would need to find soldiers that no one
would miss that no one would care about
that he could send in to do the dirty
work for him and that's when pagosian
came up with a brilliant plan recruit
Russia's undesirables go into every jail
and labor camp in Russia and offer the
most brutal violent criminals to deal of
a lifetime join the fight in Ukraine and
you can earn your freedom it was
brilliant no one would care of a bunch
of violent criminals died it would be a
good riddance and for these prisoners
who were gonna rot in jail anyways even
the smallest chance of getting out of
prison was was good enough to take and
burgosian was just the man for the job
Clinton trusted him he was hard as nails
and he himself had been in jail for more
than 10 years remember so he knew
exactly how to appeal to these desperate
prisoners join me and you can become
just as rich and Powerful as I am and
his pitch worked in 2014 the Wagner
group was formed with the evgeny
pregosian as a secret leader the Wagner
group became prune's personal private
mercenary group they became his muscle
and Putin would never admit to using
them or that they even existed while
conveniently Wagner's Soldier started
popping up everywhere Russia had
political or business interests you
Ukraine Syria and most of Africa became
the Wagner group's playground and
wherever they went they would steal as
many natural resources as possible
making progosian even richer by late
2015 pregosian had become far more than
just Putin's chef and it wasn't long
before he started to attract the
attention of Russia's enemies
foreign
[Music]
was quickly becoming one of the richest
most influential oligarchs in Russia in
2016 he helped poon interfere in
America's presidential elections through
another company he founded and even
though pagosian never admitted to being
the leader of the Wagner group most of
the West knew that he was so he became
one of the most sanctioned Russian
oligarchs out there his businesses were
sanctioned he was sanctioned even his
mother was hit with sanctions from the
West it was an all-out Financial war
against poon's right-hand man he even
reached the point where pagosian was
added to the FBI's 10 Most Wanted
fugitive list with a 250 000 Bounty
Craig ocean was the god that poon could
count on to do his dirty work so when
Russia and video Ukraine again in 2022
who else did poon called up but his old
friend pagosian Wagner mercenaries were
sent into Ukraine to assassinate the
presidents and when that didn't work out
they stayed behind to help Russian
soldiers fight on the ground which sent
progression to the front lines in 2022
he finally admitted to being the leader
of the Wagner group and used that
publicity to start recruiting even more
prisoners into his ranks his argument if
the prisoners didn't fight Russian kids
would be forced to it seemed that
progression had just gone all out to
support Putin and the Russian invasion
of Ukraine which made what happened less
than a year later so surprising
a coin to progosian his march on Moscow
on June 23 2023 was never a coup
according to him it was a protest to
remove military officials responsible
for lying about the war in Ukraine but
that didn't matter to the rest of the
world it looked like progression was
taking onpune directly Vagner sojas were
leaving their Post in Ukraine and
launching an attack on the Kremlin but
if that was really the case it raises a
lot of questions Putin and progression
have been friends in Alice for years
pregocian had obviously proven his
loyalty to Putin even while Putin was
taking out Russian oligarchs all over
the world so why would yevguini publicly
betray Putin had he planned the coup
with Putin to get rid of Russian
military leaders he didn't trust did the
CIA pay progression to do it or was
progression simply stirring the pot to
see just how much support he could get
for taking out Putin and why was the
head of Belarus the one that brokered
the deal for progression to be exiled to
Belarus a pro-russian country with deep
ties to the Kremlin and why was it
reported that pagosian is apparently
back in Russia less than two weeks after
the incidents and if this was an actual
case of mutiny you can guarantee that
ocean is gonna get assassinated well
that Putin is going to get assassinated
for showing weakness or both and on both
people in the west might be cheering
this on thinking that Putin is about to
go down you want to be careful what you
wish for because as far as Russian
dictators go Putin has been relatively
stable and predictable but if he's
thrown out whoever ends up replacing him
could be a whole lot worse
while the Wagner group has been fighting
Russia's Secret Wars the US has also
been fighting their own secret war in a
country Far Far Away in a country that
most of you have never heard of and this
secret American war is arguably way
worse than Ukraine 377 000 people have
died sixty percent of which die from
starvation unsafe drinking water or not
being able to get medical care a war
that some called the greatest
humanitarian crisis on the planet right
now and yeah we never hear about this
war on the news why because unlike
Ukraine in this war America is clearly
the evil ones so the powers that be
would rather you not know about it and
what war is this the war in Yemen the
war in Yemen has been absolutely brutal
and it's still happening right now as we
speak and America is involved for one
reason and one reason only to keep the
Saudi royal family happy and we expose
all of America's misdees in the Yemen
war in our new private documentary that
is definitely too spicy to be posted
publicly in fact it's already age
restricted and you can watch it right
now by clicking the card on the screen
click the card on the screen to watch
now
[Music]
foreign